well hello reject them
I'm Greg Alva this here is Amy castle
sand castle Inc amy castling Inc go
check out her channel on YouTube I shot
a video with her on her channel rare
recently it's not up yet then I will
ladies a mother effing f-word Adobe LC
oh it is good he'll just wait for you
tonight they're gonna have some laughs
that's 49 I'm sure Amy yeah Amy yeah
have you seen Despicable Me Films I have
they're great well there's a clip out
called minions take the stage because
they're obviously the best thing out of
the despicable franchise what's the
thing that we eat like a casserole my
casserole calzone 20 calories like we're
here it's like the cheese and the
marinara on the calzone which I eat I
like the minions and small doses I'm
sure this will really have nothing to do
with the movie la la la la la la la
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
cute I think that scene because in
Despicable Me 3 GRU is taking on the
villain play about one of the creators
of South Park tow is like a 1980s
villain and I'm thinking that right
there is meant to be a diversion called
puddin the peepers yeah hmm right there
I'm the dancing and all that reminds me
very reminiscent of with the old-time
movies where they would do the
synchronized swimming and the different
things of shots overhead yeah yeah I
think that's how you dance right every
time your dog as unless I'm in a pool
with lots of water when I listen to you
speak I imagine you sound like a minion
not really listening a Pacific thought
in my head oh yeah yeah I only 1000 mean
looking like 1 2 oh no you're like a
more attractive minion how more as like
my dragon we don't know those minions
are hot I'll dye my hair yellow Oh oh my
god you be such a hectic day
Halloween detective minion and if you
can become of a cyclops minion then you
be really going for sex you're right I
love the minions oh I do too I don't
know how to define what the me like if
someone said to you it what are the
minions I think there are emotions I
sent they're like our modern-day Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs yeah that's
been incredibly dumb
[Music]
there was like apology so that's funny
his energy emoji movies which we're
gonna watch - yay but no it's like
they're all these different emotions or
feelings and like that's all they are no
they're not anything else well I mean
this is seven Dorf so each representing
one specific emotion the minions are
just a crane yeah they're just uh
they're all bipolar yeah they're all
like schizophrenic but they're
representing that yeah I bet there's
like a staff of writers who have the
brilliant mind and understand who the
minions really are maybe I should just
watch the minions movie so I can try to
understand who they are inside the mind
of the minions at the mind of a minion
because they kind of represent my
mentality do they yeah a lot of times I
do about alive oh yeah that's how I feel
order - yeah and I take orders - very
well just so you know Amy
oh good to know oh yeah I'm a submissive
that's not that's not that doesn't
belong a restrictive no come on cut me
some slack well I think of what I'm
thinking about the Binion's yeah those
are the noises I make - you're nothing
and yeah can't get enough of that oh
yeah that's one that some women are very
turned off just so you know good to know
just called how to flirt with Greg Alba
Amy Kennedy's I don't watch it out in
front for a time yeah that's you take
child characters you turn them into
something perverted are you doing Dan
that's how you make content on YouTube
now you can subscribe to the real
rejects also click that notification
Bell cookies drive buttons aren't
anything anymore notifications are
important that are very important Amy
castle sand castle ink it's amy castle a
bunch of different ways of finding a
castle on the interweb just type in AV
castle instagram twitter see my whole
life
whole life many years long they're
totally worth it she's got this awesome
food-related channel if you like food
and you like pretty women and you're
gonna again you're going to find it
reasonably enjoyable by you that much we
have a patreon up right now which has a
lot of exclusive video content on there
we got behind the scenes footage deleted
takes exclusive like a video podcast and
there's a look-see I realize that like
I've been posting like random videos on
our patreon that kind of serve as mini
vlogs and so I think you have just you
know for any any any amount you pledge I
don't matter I'm not going to make a go
specific rewards you become a patron
whether it's a dollar or whatever you'll
get access to the mini vlogs that I post
throughout the week I think that's a
sound funny Anessa sound financial
investments right there that's a sound
financial investment notice people I
always get back to the patrons are my
family Lily their first priority yeah
show that no you saw that sounds so let
them direct towards me but oh yeah but
you felt that you wanted